when the supreme court overturned roe
versus wade it did more than just allow
states to ban abortion
it showed how this court views rights
not explicitly listed in the
constitution it's really difficult to
exaggerate the importance of this
decision the court has pulled a complete
180. going from recognizing a
constitutional right and individual
right to saying 50 years later no
we are mistaken
here's the legal reasoning behind that
180 and why even though the court's
opinion made clear it applies solely to
abortion some legal experts think the
same methodology could be used to revise
other rulings
the framers wrote the bill of rights the
amendments to the constitution to well
list the rights americans have
the right to free speech to bear arms to
not have soldiers in your house during
peace time you know them and at some
point specifically at the ninth one they
wrapped it up by saying this list isn't
exhaustive and there are other rights
not named here that cannot be denied or
disparaged or in 18th century
terminology the rate's not in the
enumeration so the ninth amendment is
there essentially to say that there are
unenumerated rights right that the list
um in the bill of rights uh at the time
um was not intended to be exclusive uh
and so then the difficult part becomes
figuring out what those unenumerated
rates are the supreme court has long
seen the right to privacy as one it
established that right in cases
involving raising children that parents
have the right to teach them another
language or send them to private school
and in cases involving having children
that the government could not sterilize
convicted criminals
and in the landmark 1965 case griswold
vs connecticut which was based on these
earlier rulings that overturned a
connecticut ban on contraception
in the opinion the supreme court ruled
that marital privacy even though not
mentioned explicitly in the constitution
is one of those unenumerated rights
protected by the ninth amendment
and that right meant using birth control
was a private decision and couldn't be
banned by the state
there was a lot of different kind of
ideas of privacy that flowed from
griswold cases that expanded the right
to birth control the right to same-sex
relations and eventually marriage were
based on these cases that established
privacy as an unenumerated right that
was sort of a constellation of privacy
interests that arose in that way
the right to an abortion was one of
those that was established based on
these rulings the phrase in in roe v
wade it says that the right to privacy
that was identified in griswold is broad
enough to encompass the decision to
end an unwanted pregnancy
the row opinion mentioned that right
could also be found in another amendment
the 14th which says no one shall be
deprived of liberty without due process
it says we believe that's based on the
liberty clause
of the 14th amendment or the due process
clause another name for that clause
roh is from tradition that looks at
these concepts of liberty
and equality very broadly okay it
applies them very broadly to new
circumstances and to
a society that is different than the
society that we had in the 18th century
but two of the justices thought that was
too broad of an interpretation the
dissenters in 1973 said that the
constitution is silent on this matter it
doesn't say anything about abortion one
way or the other and this court has no
business interfering with the
legislature's judgment about how to
regulate a pregnancy
and that's pretty much the reasoning
that the court has adopted now
in overturning roe the court wrote that
an unenumerated right should be deeply
rooted in this nation's history and
tradition
and ruled that the constitution does not
confer a right to abortion the
methodology is called originalism
where you stick very closely to what you
think
the
authors of the passage
understood it to mean what the public
understood the passage to mean
at the time it was adopted but some
legal experts and civil rights activists
are concerned about how this methodology
could be applied to some of these other
rulings involving privacy like in
griswold or in obergefell versus hodges
which legalized same-sex marriage in
2015 but the majority wrote that those
cases do not destroy potential life like
abortion they even wrote nothing in this
opinion should be understood to cast
doubt on precedents that do not concern
abortion
but the dissenters argued that even if
the majority's word is trusted
that law has a way of evolving without
regard to original intentions and
whatever today's majority might say one
thing really does lead to another this
broader approach to applying the liberty
concepts and equality concepts of the
constitution the current majority of the
supreme court is very skeptical of that
and that doesn't mean that they are
eager necessarily to overrule those
precedents or different conditions and
different facts that apply to each of
them
but as a matter of principle yes those
would be on on shaky grounds the idea
that they would be overruled wholesale
the way that roe versus wade has been
overruled
a little harder to imagine because of
the social acceptance is broader the
court is certainly saying this is just
about abortion but there are kind of
there's a breadcrumb trail the court is
leaving in the future if it wants to go
further than abortion and i don't think
we can rule that out um indefinitely
experts like ziegler say there's no
immediate prospect that these other
rulings would be reversed but the
supreme court views unenumerated rights
much differently than previous courts
and that may play out in future cases